ich habe überhaupt aufnahme gedrückt
aber hast du ja
hallo leute ich jetzt wieder auch immer
noch willkommen zu einem neuen video
heute teste ich alles mit zitrone es
gibt wirklich sehr viele sachen und ich
hab zitronen dekorieren das mache ich
natürlich nicht alleine sondern mit
also ich muß schon mal sagen meine
nichte war wirklich äußerst aufgeregt
darüber dass ich mit nina schubert oder
es ist ja ein neuer song rausgekommen
genau ja jetzt am freitag die halter von
der song chemie nello 26
und er ist benannt nach einer zitrone
tee ist nur auf sizilien gibt
ja die ganze gefragt hat für mich ja ich
habe diese zitronen halt ich war vor
zwei einem monat oder so habe ich das
songs geschrieben mit meinem team und
wir waren in seiner villa in italien und
unter zitronenbäumen dann habe ich so
einmal so eine zitrone abgerissen und
habe die so gegessen und eine schale hat
so gut gerochen und ich hab's vergessen
und die schale hat selbst gut geschmeckt
von dieser zitrone ja andere sagen mein
song handelt von gebrochenem herzen
keine ahnung vertrauen dass das thema
ich freue mich mehr dazu heute da
ja wie gesagt ich würde erstmal was
trinken wollen ja ich auch haben mankell
ist auch ein bisschen trocken also
falls jetzt jemand das nicht gecheckt
hat und eins zu eins und eins
zusammengezählt hat einen song handelt
von zitronen genau
heute werden
und hessen machen mit zitronen
mit limonade es gibt ja sehr viel im
nadelstreif kante hand ist mit orange ja
mettinger fassbrause
er war gut
ja es ist schon aufgefallen wir haben
sehr viel gemeinsam kommen beide aus
hamburg ja aus der nähe von hamburg aber
wir sagen aber ist dass hamburg
wahrscheinlich machst du das auch so
hier ist also oettinger fast browser
gibt es eine müssen wir irgendwie wert
von 1 bis 10 ja von einer zitrone bis
zehn zitrone oder nähe von einer
kriminelle bis 10 fällen los 10 4 - das
ist so lecker - familie okay okay okay
ich finds lecker aber mit hier die säure
bisschen das schmeckt irgendwie
überhaupt nicht findet
ich mag kein bier schmeckt wie so ein
radler was was sich ein richtiges
rangenommen schmeckt den fake radler
also für mich ist es für mich ist eine
drei von zehn jahre würde ich mitgehe
ich würde mir niemals kaufen sollte
siemens legen macht das eine fassbrause
die stechert pack ich mir jetzt aber
meint die polizei wann wird die sich
einverleibt okay dann als nächstes die
laminate mir gefällt das hier ist es ein
guter oder abgeben wie fühlst du dich in
so einem test video ich fühle mich sehr
gut ja ich mag das auch gerne ist auch
glaube ich ein hobby von mir sachen
empfehlen und bewerten
es aber auch über so einen supermarkt
geht und die sachen dann schaust du dir
so stundenlang sachen durch diesen kann
ja das produkt kenne ich noch nicht und
was ich am liebsten mache wenn ich
irgendwo in anderen ländern bin dann
gehe ich in supermärkte ja und da bleibe
ich dann auch unser lernst du das land
richtig kennenlernen
richtig kennen könnte es auch einfach
mal eine flasche macht das doch ich will
hier auf bestellung
ich habe richtig entertainment gerade
wurde die sau raus gelassen bis sie was
ich kann nicht glauben dass es wahr ist
ich suche nach dem haken an regentagen
großen träume
strom länger außen gaben
anderen sei auch richtig gut vorbereitet
sieht gut aus findet vom design her
gefällt es hier
letmathe
das mag ich das schmeckt mir schmeckt
nicht so der aschenbecher wie normale
martin schmeckt wie eine bessere mate
einfach schmeckt richtig lecker lecker
lecker dass zucker aus bio drin das
schmeckt man für acht von zehn firmen
nennt uns geht es tatsächlich ist das
comeback ist hergestellt abgefüllt
brauhaus hand nimmt wächst wird in
bremen glaube ich produziert oder ist
das so ja aber das ist in den farben
weiß was es manchmal ist weil man gibt
ja die flaschen aber glaubst du nein ich
schreibe es in die kommentare wenn ihre
stop die einfachen becks flasche nehmen
dürfen ja zu dieser anleihe muss mir ja
gar nicht sagen darf ich noch was ein
ständig von nur noch raus nehmen danke
da gibt es einfach nichts zu sagen sie
nur zehn von zehn das ist eine familie
und das ist einfach eine familie in
einer flaschenform
entschuldigung schulz ich finde wir
bleiben doch einmal einen drink sie
bleiben und vielleicht lockt uns das ein
bisschen hierauf in guter alter
limoncello
hatte die in italien bei deiner songs
herrschen auch die modelle nein leider
nicht misst
sollte cool aussehen
wer zitronig absolut ja es hat so ein
bisschen dr zitronenaroma und was ich
mir auch gut vorstellen könnte ist wenn
man das so ein bisschen wenn man
zitronenkuchen und damit irgendwie sowas
wie eine füllung machen jetzt haben wir
die getränke wird es noch mal mit
irgendeinem zitronen und nachspielen
wie zitrone gerade der kampf zitronen
als zitronen offen bevor das ziel ist
also wir fangen wir ganz nah an jetzt
mit den lebensmitteln ich weiß gar nicht
wie ich das nennen soll snacks
süßigkeiten es sind glaube ich keinen
lebensmittel snacks leckermäulchen
leckermäulchen tut leckermäulchen
ja
voller schaum sehr wolkig
mein gott ich habe so lange kann der
kann man gegessen frage nicht
funktioniert zitrone mit ich sehe ja
immer zitrone mit milchprodukten finde
ich manchmal schwierig auch merkt man es
auch nicht wird sie also die vanille
version kann ich sehr empfehlen aber
jetzt die finde ich schwierig wie viele
familien los willst du hier
parteien 4
ja also nicht nein nein eklig ist es
nicht schmeckt es ist komisch aber ich
finde es schmeckt ein bisschen nach
strom
ja es gibt doch manche sachen die für
mich ein bisschen nach strom
also reisen kann ich noch verstehen
je nach geschmack ist so sehr strom inc
er war irgendwas damit anfangen könnten
jetzt probieren möchte so sagt mir was
willst du als erstes problem die da
kennst du dir ja ich liebe die du liebe
wie ich war noch im supermarkt sachen
sind nämlich nicht dass ich liebe die
ich habe die früher so wir haben
gegessen erfrischung stückchen magst du
die nicht ich habe so lange wieder nicht
gegessen
kriegen wir das auch immer so aus klar
mein gott ich feiere das so
da sind derjenige schott ich mag das
also für mich ist eine neun von zehn ich
bring mit dir auf jeden fall weil alle
musiker haben ja an produkte und ich
finde zu dir würden dann erfrischungs
steht und dann würde ich so pleite gehen
wir einfach
aber du willst dich wieder kohle machen
weil sie nie nackt schub man könnte ihn
mit dem man cello füllen und mein gott
warum hast du denn noch keine super
tipps
und das komplett geplant ich habe sogar
leute die sprünge kraus für meine tour
und werden dies weil man natur werden
verkauft werden hoffentlich werde ich
freue mich sehr dass mit gail janina
tour gespielt wird grün war das mit
musik also wann hast du damit so richtig
angefangen dann kam so dellen ersten
also ich habe angefangen eigentlich
schon ganz früh mit 7 habe ich
angefangen klavier zu spielen weil die
an mozart heiraten wollte und dann habe
ich irgendwann so mein klavierlehrer
sowas auch sofort visum und meinte er
sich gesangsunterricht nehmen soll dann
habe ich ein stipendium bekommen habe
gesang gemacht und dann hatte ich
irgendwann meine erste band aber es war
nie so ernsthaft und dann bin ich nach
berlin gezogen wollte eigentlich regie
studiert habe aber währenddessen so aus
spaß und song hochgeladen für mich und
meine freunde auf youtube kamen die
ersten produzenten auf mich zu und dann
habe ich ein praktikum gemacht weil ich
fand es war erst ein halbes leid
und dann habe ich ein praktikum
abgebrochen und habe angefangen musik zu
machen darf ein management kennen
gelernt und dann ging das einfach so
weiter
was möchtest du denn als nächstes von
unserer großen auswahl hier
könne die ganz interessant ja ja ja komm
jacobi firma dieckmann
die lemon cheesecake
ich habe drauf gesessen ja auf dem
hierfür einen entschuldigungs könnt ihr
ein bisschen eingemotteten ich habe
während der fahrt vielleicht mal drauf
gesessen die riechen gut
ja ja
schön focus
[Musik]
dass diese summer edition bergkamen bloß
besser hier auf jeden fall
ein langohr ich habe extrem lange arme
ist
dieses problem ich habe ein sehr sehr
kleinen kopf und sie hat sehr lange
arbeitet ist und so unfassbar lang haben
vergleichen ich habe wirklich lange arme
ich habe die längsten leute und
bewertung achso
646 würde ich auch sagen
ja seine erfrischungs stäbchen von 10 10
heja ich bereits nicht so enttäuscht
würde 5 m - geben gut wird es gerne
probieren ja ja
ich bin ja die beste grundwissen
bäckerin und ich hatte auch überlegt
auch nicht die strömungen macke habe ich
dann nicht gemacht darüber hätte aber
management immer gehen sollen ja aber
ich kann sehr guten eindruck machen
deswegen bin ich jetzt umso gespannter
weil man es ein teil naja
ich hab ich habe 20 jahre keinen strom
berichtete
besser machen es ist für mich eine nette
gemeinschaft
das wird man erst mal nicht hunderte
[Applaus]
forscher gegenüber druck wird tut mir
leid mit dem sechs familien ja ja ja
schon besser als erfrischung steht jetzt
ein bisschen kritisch hier gerade
stimmung kippt meinungen unterscheiden
sich nun auch ein grosser favorit
hiernach yogurette also da als ich das
gesehen habe dachte ich mir das
universum will ich gerade ein bisschen
rausnehmen weil diese ganzen zitronen
version jetzt auch yogurette mit zitrone
das ja eigentlich mit erdbeer und genau
das habe ich halt alles jetzt gemacht
für den release dass da einfach auch
ganz viel auf dem markt ist so dass es
dass man sich sofort
an mich denken muss
ach ja hier stets auch die
zusammenarbeit mit nina turbo core ist
auch was aus meinem kühlschrank essen
sollte auch wenn du nicht so ein
schokoladenkuchen fan bist
ich weiß nicht wer versuchen gefällt mir
besser wir haben sich hier was getraut
da wurde sich was getraut wurde auch mal
was versucht das sehen wir schokolade
und zitrone ist es eine gute kombination
weiß ich nichts mehr frische und
stäbchen sich bei dem hier bei den
apfelsinen und zitronen schnitten das
finde ich das könnte so ein richtiges
ddr süßigkeit sein das ist bestimmt eine
ddr süßigkeit
[Musik]
schön dass wir mal die zitrone also wir
haben hier so schokoladen sonnen
schnittchen also dass du wirklich nicht
nur kennst du das wenn man sagt dass
etwas vollmundig schmeckt wenn er das
ist das gegenteil zu anti folgen es
schmeckt so leer so unfassbar leer ist
nicht dass es nur 22 ich glaube das wird
auch bald aus dem sortiment
so sieht mir das auch nach 100 jahren
etliche leute die ddr ich bin meinen
echten möchte jetzt die du bist aber
crazy drei outfits etwa die softail cola
und zitrone
hier komme ich bin ich dachte kann es
ganz einfach
du einfach mal auch das
aber es kommt auch dann auch den ich
muss raus machen soll ich machen
[Musik]
probiert
naja
schmeckt nach sauna aufguss von der
schmeckt auf strom da schmeckt eine
sauna aufguss aber so einer wo man
danach die sonne legt das immer wieder
ganz nett ich zur seite
24 es ist eine 2 es ist eine 2 zu den
soft mit den anderen soft case hat
wirklich nicht gut zu tun schmeckt nicht
so
ich merke auch wie wodka mit kohl also
kohler mit wodka was ist nicht links
langen durch moskau ja meine auch ja ja
ja
ich mache einfach ich auch lieblich
liebe ingwer beim sushi ist auch wenn
das immer so auch ich habe wieder so
rein ja und manche essen das nicht bin
also kann ich irgendwie haben und dann
riecht also ganz ehren los wir auf den
anderen
doch irgend wenn ich aufhöre und das
schmeckt aber nach seife magst du körper
zitronen aber wir sind noch lange nicht
nein nein da gibt es doch noch so viel
mehr guck mal mama mag man einfach aber
wir sehen so sie es aus
sie sehen ganz gut aus die original sind
auch aufgegangen
ja
so ist
es irgendwie im bezirk in dem ich eine
nostalgische acht von zehn 59 7 15 als
nächstes haben wir die zitronencreme
schokolade mit zitronen und
ich finde irgendwie sie die lucky aus
weil ich kann mir vorstellen dass es die
auch in pfefferminz version wird
gamecity und nrw
irgendwas wirklich so eine schokolade ja
ja ja ja ja
qualität
das ist wie wenn du einfach so auf so
vettweiß das ist ja ein klecks ist meine
damen und herren lagen
präsentieren wir ihnen
constanze mozart kugeln in weiß
geschmack liegen
[Applaus]
das gesehen habe dass sie auch wieder
das universum will mir ein zeichen
schicken dass nina dabei alles gebrannt
über ähnlich sieht aus wie eine halloren
kugel ja ich liebe halloren konnte ich
auch in die kassen der zitrone plane ich
hätte jetzt noch so gern gegessen
unfassbar
[Musik]
schrecklich
ich frage mich welche zielgruppe der
welt das kaufen ich sehe immer gewinnt
selbstverständlich immer nur folgen wenn
oma so ziellos einfach so in den
süßigkeiten links zeit dann gebe ich nur
4 ich gebe sondern mit 33 ehrlich wer du
bist ganz schön frech ja ich meine was
ja was gibst du ja heimlich rand auch
nicht versteckt hinter dir und gibt auch
mit 3 dass beides ist mein favorit
könnte es so so könnte ich mir einen tag
am see vorstellen oder
ich sage hier wirklich das obwohl das
koffein drin hab ich bin auch gar nicht
na ja ich wollte mein image nicht so
schnell klar das sind die top produkte
mit zitronengeschmack leute ja
ja ja ja so sieht es also aus an einem
dienstagnachmittag
tageszeiten wartezeit
tolles oder hier war danke dass ich hier
sein dürfte ich freue mich sehr klar und
ihr höre ich jetzt den neuen song von
nina anja vitamine und dann sagt mal in
den in den kommentaren wie viele
kriminelle sie denn für den sommer ja
bewertet würde mich sehr freuen
jazznacht